welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man
and this episode we're breaking down
captain america the winter soldier
whenever someone says that the mcu movie
such as theme park rides
this is the film i point to the
political spy thriller is filled to the
brim with subtext
social commentary and easter eggs that
easily make it one of the best movies
that marvel has ever made
what's more is that the film gets even
better after you binge watch the
infinity saga
and throughout this video we're going to
be pointing out the best details that
only come to fruition after you've seen
every movie from iron man all the way up
to far from home
some of these easter eggs may have
popped up in other videos but i
guarantee there's a couple here that you
haven't seen before
so make sure you stick around until the
end there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you aren't fully caught up on all
23 films then i highly recommend that
you snap yourself
out of here if you enjoyed this video
then please hit that like button
as it massively helps us out and make
sure you subscribe for a marvel movie
breakdown every week
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into captain america
the winter soldier
okay so in the winter soldier we learn
that bucky actually survived his fall in
the prior film
he was found by hydra and experimented
on leading to him becoming a twisted
version of captain america
instead of a shield he has a metal arm
but there's also some amazing shots
laced throughout the movie that subtly
hint at the similarities between the two
if you've been watching our other
breakdowns then you'll know we always
examine the parallels between
certain moments and though you might not
notice them your subconsciousness
definitely does
this allows you to draw conclusions over
the character rocks
and no more of these examples more
present in captain america
and the winter soldier the angle in
which cap was first created
also mirrors the angle in which we
approach bucky as we join him having his
memory wiped
a shot of bucky also mirrors one of
cap's final journey in the first avenger
and the two both visit the howling
commandos display wearing similar
clothing
throughout the mcu there are shots that
have been purposely chosen to show
similarities between the two
and i believe that these have been put
in place to show how they are basically
a mirror image of one another
similar to cap bucky is a man out of
time that has been selected for specific
missions
and thanks to his super soldier serum he
completes them with these
however whereas cap was working
predominantly for shield
bucky was working predominantly for
hydra who
just also happens to be within shield
anyway these are some amazing little
parallels between the two that remind
you of just how similar that they are
and why cap would eventually go against
the avengers in order to save his friend
in civil war
civil war itself also has several
callbacks to this film
most namely the interactions between
bucky and cap
steve says you know me and winter
soldier before asking
do you know me in civil war he also
tries to tell him that he's his friend
when calming him down
which two is a reason that he gives
stock as to why he's protecting the
character
bucky even puts his arm around skinny
steve and says come on man and leads him
away
which is also similar to how the two
leave at the end of civil war
these aren't the only shots in the movie
that reference other things either
as in our iron man 3 video we discussed
how tony and cap
both had pretty similar arcs throughout
their trilogy i don't want to just recap
what i said in that breakdown
but this film reminds us of cap's
sacrifice at the end of the first
adventure
he kept a photo of peggy as he crashed
the hydra plane on what was seemingly a
one-way ticket
and this was echoed in tony who tried to
reach out to peppa as he potentially
flew to his death in order to get the
nuke away from new york
whereas tony got to go home to her steve
was frozen in the ice
and it would take a long long time
before he was able to truly hold peggy
in his arms once more
speaking of long long time we actually
hear this song long long time by kitty
callin
playing in steve's apartment in the
movie and this song returns for the
final dance between him and peggy at the
end of end game
[Music]
in winter soldier we actually learned
that peggy has dementia
and during her conversation with steve
there are a lot of things that hint
towards his actions in endgame
firstly she says the best thing we can
do is start over and steve would of
course do this at the end of that film
now depending on what time travel theory
you subscribe to for endgame
may also add some cool little details
here whilst the russos disagree
the writers of the movie say that steve
always went back and lived out his life
with peggy
and this is why her husband's identity
was hidden throughout the movie
peggy reacts in a way that seems to be
almost how she would have reacted upon
seeing him return at the end of that
film
and it is possible that this was
deliberately set out like this
the writers themselves said that they
planned out steve's time travelling
all the way back in the first avenger
and that this is why they laced so many
lines about the last dance throughout it
though it contradicts the understanding
of how the roosters laid out time travel
and endgame
if steve was always meant to go back
then this would mean that no branch
timelines would be created
and thus this line still rings true
yeah you're alive
you came you came back it's
been so long
so long well i couldn't leave my best
girl
now and she owes me dance during civil
war we also learn that agent 13 is
actually the niece of peggy
wait wait you kissed your own niece what
however there's also a line that hints
towards this in the winter soldier when
sharon says that she's been on the phone
to her aunt who has insomnia
insomnia is a common symptom of dementia
and this is a nicer
easter egg that shows marvel knew
exactly what they were doing with the
character
peggy isn't the only character alongside
bucky to return from the first avenger
either
and in the movie we meet the ai
recreation of anim zola
zola had his consciousness uploaded to a
machine after defecting to the us
and building hydra within shield the
machine was actually shown in the
background of endgame
and zola was seen for a split second in
the film when steve and tony was
sneaking around the base
in addition to all of this zola's
appearance as a screen was actually
hinted at in the first avenger
with a nice bit of foreshadowing that
suggested the way that things were going
to happen
i told you these marvel guys don't miss
a beat
when zola is presenting elements of the
past most namely the death of howard
stock
we get a quick flash of a newspaper and
can see that this was released on
december 17th
1991. this date has appeared throughout
the mcu
and it was even an ironman one with a
similar report
in civil war we see the cctv footages
dated the 16th of december 1991
so they were killed on this night and
then the newspaper was released the
following day
this is likely also when steve learned
that bucky had killed the starks
which of course was a big point in civil
war speaking of howard in the first
avenger he remarks that hydra won't be
coming at them with a pocketknife
however in this film the winter soldier
literally attacks them with a
pocketknife at one point
other cool at least directs that we've
noticed throughout our mcu binge
is that matthew ellis appears for a
split second as a target for hydra
we learn in iron man 3 that he was the
president and this is a nice carryover
for this film
maria hill is also spotted for a split
second during this targeting scene and
we get a quick glimpse at tony stark who
is sat in the remodeled avengers tower
dr strange is also name dropped as a
target by sitwell
and i don't know something about this
guy
doesn't sit well with me hey you haven't
that
now there's actually a hint that sitwell
is a two-faced character early on in the
mcu
as when he first appeared in thor he was
shown in a way similar to how gemini
symbols often appear
which can be a symbol of duality senator
stern also appears from iron man 2
and there's some really nice carryovers
from the other films now whilst the
hydra twist is one of the biggest
what moments in the mcu there are some
minor clues that things are up with them
way before we find out for example when
nick fury is shot in cap's apartment the
radio responded to agent 13
seems to know that this has happened
before he's even told it
showing that this was indeed an inside
job if you watch the mcu in
chronological order 2
captain marvel inevitably pops up before
this film
in that movie fury tells carol that his
friends call him fury and his enemies
call him nick
and in this film alexander pierce calls
him nick and not fury
suggesting that he's indeed a bad guy
also when captain america gets onto the
elevator
before the big action scene there's a
couple of things that hint at something
being up with those that also get on
board with him
this scene has been picked apart a lot
but one thing i haven't seen
anyone point out is that we can see the
men in suits wearing tactical boots
instead of formal shoes as they're just
in an office building
they wouldn't need to wear these unless
they were gearing up for a fight
another cool little detail happens when
rumlow hits him with an electrified stun
stick
and when doing this both of them shake
as the current passes through the two
showing that he was getting heard just
as much as cap was
the location itself actually holds a lot
of significance too
as cap enters the elevator we can
actually see the watergate complex in
the background
this is of course where the infamous
watergate scandal happened
that eventually led to the president
resigning watergate involved the
government spying on its own people
similar to how hydra do and this little
easter egg is a nice hint towards the
movie's plot
an elevator scene just like this would
reappear in end game
however steve would use the things he
learned in this movie to stop a fight
breaking out
and the hail hydra line is still
hilarious to me
if you read secret empire then you'll
know why because
man the internet did not like that the
movie of course opens with us being
introduced to sam wilson
and cap doing laps around him and saying
on your left
maybe you should change his nickname to
lapse instead of
cut never mind this of course makes a
big return in end game
but one thing that you might not have
noticed is that when sam approaches old
man rogers at the lake bench
he does it from his left along with sam
now also plays a big part in this movie
as well
and he arguably becomes one of steve's
closest allies
she of course doesn't want to get rid of
being bffs with hawkeye though
and you might have noticed in the film
that she has an arrow necklace which is
of course a call back to clint
nick fury plays a big part too as not
only is his death
instrumental to some of the events in
agents of shield but the lines he drops
also play a much larger part in the
overall universe
when first introducing cap to the new
heli carriers he says that stark helped
to make them routeless
throughout our breakdowns we've often
talked about how tony learns from his
mistakes
and some great examples of how he uses
an energy shield and end game
after using a nano one in infinity war
caused him to deplete his armor
in the avengers we saw that he and steve
both wasted valuable time trying to
restart one of the engines
and this led to tony becoming stuck in a
router and almost dying
here the engines are now routeless so
this can't happen in the future
fury also talks about how the last time
he trusted someone he lost an
eye and this of course happened in
captain marvel after he told
goose that he trusted him alexander
pierce two discusses a mission in bogota
which fury played a big part in in
captain marvel we learned that fury's
missions tended to be all set in
countries with a b
and he said so far he'd been to belfast
bucharest
belgrave and budapest he liked the bees
because he can make a rhyme
when explaining how he was able to fake
his own death fury mentions that bruce
banner worked on a toxin that slowed
down his heart rate
in the incredible hulk we learned an
elevated heartbeat was one of the main
factors that unleashed the beast
so it makes sense that he would have
spent time trying to perfect a device to
stop
any chance of the rage monster coming
out cap also jumps out of a plane with
no parachute
and i think this might be a nod to the
incredible hulk in which brewster's the
same before landing in harlem
he also did it in ragnarok to a much
funnier effect
at the end of the movie the triskelion
is destroyed and a subtle nod to this
actually pops up in spider-man
homecoming when the class are on their
field trip to washington
they pass a sign that says try skelly
and clean up and this shows the damage
caused by the building's collapse
has had long lasting repercussions
natasha also tells steve that he's a
terrible liar
after he says he doesn't know what fury
was doing in his apartment
pierce later asks him the same question
and he answers with the same thing
but in a slightly different way taking
advice from that
i was fury in your apartment
i don't know you're a terrible liar
captain why was nick in your apartment
listening
i don't know the movie ends with the
heroes winning and taking down hydra
but it sort of feels like a big loss
nick fury has to fake his own death
and at his grave we actually see on his
tombstone that the quote is the same one
that jules dropped in pulp fiction from
ezekiel 25 17.
maria hell gets a job at stark
industries and she actually has to take
a lie detector test
probably because they know she's a spy
and
as we learned hydra agents are
everywhere bucky ventures to the museum
to learn more about his past
and we can see that the captain america
mannequin has been removed after cap
took his uniform back
i hope stanley didn't get fired for that
but it's a nice little consistency that
ties the film together
the movie ends with the tease for age of
ultron and you should definitely go
check out my breakdown of that film
if you haven't already now obviously i
know this movie is packed with easter
eggs and there's been a ton of
breakdowns on it
so i hope you had fun with this and got
to see some ones that you hadn't noticed
before
if you did notice any that i didn't then
comment below and let me know
and please drop a thumbs up as it
massively helps us out
make sure you check out our breakdown of
captain marvel at the end if you haven't
and make sure you subscribe as we go
over a marvel movie every week
so if you want to see a specific film's
easter eggs then
it's probably either on our channel
already or is coming up in the future
if you want to support us from as little
as 99 cents a month then please click
the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with the channel so hopefully we
see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thank you for taking the
time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
me